ابدا معك اسماعيل ابو عمر
و المعارك المستمره في اكثر من محور اين
تكثفت هذه المعارك في اي
محاور نعم المحور الرئيسي في هذه اللحظات
الذي يشهد اشتباكات ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ومنطقه معسكر خانيونس لكن
الابرز في ذلك بان قوات الاحتلال في هذه
اللحظات تحاصر مدارس تاوي نازحين الاف
النازحين في محيط مدرسه حياه وكذلك مدرسه
قنديله في معسكر يونس ومنذ صباح هذا اليوم
وحتى هذه اللحظه هناك 14 شهيدا وصلوا الى
مستشفى ناصر جراء اطلاق النار من قناصه
الاحتلال باتجاه المواطنين داخل هذه
المدرسه وما زالت هذه الاليات تحاصر
المدرسه وهناك صعوبه بالغه في نقل
الاصابات والشهداء ما بين حين واخر حيث
يجتهد المواطنون بنقل هذه الاصابات عبر
وسائل بدائيه باتجاه مستشفى ناصر في حين
قوات الاحتلال او حركه سيارات الاسعاف
باتجاه تلك المناطق فيها خطوره بالغه
فيصعب على سيارات الاسعاف التحرك في ظل
هذه الاجواء مع اشتداد القصف الاسرائيلي
بين الحين والاخر سواء القصف المدفعي
واطلاق النار المستمر ايضا في تلك المنطقه
الى الشرق من مجمع ناصر الطبي في محيط
مجمع ناصر الطبي ايضا منازل المواطنين
المحيطه بهذا المجمع تتعرض لقصف مدفعي
واطلاق نار من قبل اليات الاحتلال ومن قبل
ايضا قناصه الاحتلال الذين يعتلون منازل
المواطنين بالقرب من مسجد بلال وكذلك
منطقه او حيط مدرسه حياه ومدرسه قنديله في
ه في تلك المناطق اضافه الى المحور
الشمالي الغربي تحديدا في منطقه حي الامل
هناك ايضا قوات الاحتلال ما زالت تحاصر
اعداد كبيره من المواطنين داخل منازلهم
كذلك النازحين في مدارس الاواء اضافه الى
مواطنين اووا ونجحوا الى مستشفى الامل
التابع لجمعيه هلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
وهناك محاصره من قبل اليات الاحتلال لهذه
المنطقه وتدور اشتباكات ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بين الحين والاخر في تلك
المنطقه المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعبر اذرعها
العسكريه المختلفه تبنت عمليات اطلاق
قذائف مضاده للدروع باتجاه اليات الاحتلال
خاصه في محور حي الامل وكذلك منطقه
المعسكر والعمليات والاشتباكات ما زالت
مستمره بين حين والاخر لكن اشتدت في صباح
هذا اليوم خاصه في وسط محافظه خانيونس
واله هذه المنطقه كانت قوات الاحتلال قد
سيطرت عليها منذ ايام لكن جيوب المقاومه
ما زالت موجوده في تلك المنطقه وتقوم اباك
مع القوات مع قوات الاحتلال ومع اليات
الاحتلال التي تتوغل بشكل اكبر في منطقه
خانيونس تحديدا في منطقه المعسكر وكذلك
منطقه وسط البلد اضافه الى منطقه حي
الامال